what is up guys my name is Hoshino
welcome to episode 17.5 or express
episode 2 of 3d game programming in Java
alrighty so our last time we took a look
at how to actually export our our
project our game as and as a runnable
jar so that we could actually run it on
different computers and tested and stuff
like that and actually play it without
having to open eclipse and have our code
there umm this time what we're gonna do
is actually basically export our game so
that we can actually run it inside a web
browser alrighty so let's go okay first
of all we actually have to add some code
in that tells Java to run this as an
applet ok and and an applet is basically
a java application that can be run
within a web browser already let's just
jump in ok so we've got our got a game
right here and same - it seems to be
working fine um let's go ahead and go
and make a new class so we're gonna make
it in the in the core like fold up
package whatever you want to call it
it's technically called a package but in
this scene out in the graphics or input
just in the normal one right click hit
new and class ok right clicking here and
hitting new just makes makes sure that
you're actually in that package and
let's just call it mine front outlet and
hit finish alright so now we've got a
new class and if you actually remember
from like the second tutorial I believe
the second episode I went over how this
start and stop thing is very is like is
basically imperative to use when you're
making an applet and yeah I'll sort of
show you guys that now first of all stop
if you notice stop is it's never used
locally it's never used like we've never
actually all this code right here we
could delete it and the game would still
run because we haven't actually used
this code at all we've just written it
there so now we're actually going to use
it alrighty so let's go into mine from
applet and all we're gonna do first of
all is actually extends well we want it
to actually extend the applet class so
it's
sends applet and you'll have to import
it so just hit import and a Java just
wants you to add a default serial
version ID don't worry about that just
add it to remove that warning already so
what we actually want to do now is make
an object out of this display class
because this is our main class right we
want to make an object out of this in
this class so let's just go ahead and
say private display and I don't know
we'll just call it display equals new
display
so we're basically creating the display
class object within this applet class
and now I'm going to sort of go through
a few a few of the things that we need
to do for the applet to run so first of
all let's make a public void and make
sure that you call it in it has an
initialize and we're gonna set the
layout to new boarder layout all righty
and also we're gonna add display so
what's that what this is doing is
basically and we go to import portal app
basically what this is doing is actually
I better be recording this by the way
yeah I'm good okay right what this is
doing is just basically setting a layout
to our frame and actually adding so this
is kind of like because we're replacing
the jframe right instead of using this
code to actually start up the jframe
wishes what brings me to another problem
our cursor blank thing is within this J
frame so it wouldn't be effective for
our applet we will still see the cursor
in the output
alrighty or at least I think we will
because that class is affected to the
jframe we're not using a jframe anymore
because we're actually going to be
embedding it into a browser so that's
why I'm that's why we need to sort of do
the jframe code but with the applet code
so we need to add display here so over
here you see that we added the game and
game was an object of display I don't
know I just called display here you
could call it game here we're doing the
same thing we're just adding display
already and we also need to make okay
is important public void is start okay
this is what this is what code will run
when we want to start the applet so when
we load the page with the output
containing in it and what we actually
need to do here is read our start and
stop classes now two things first of all
let's make this public because it's
currently private I just noticed that
and obviously we can't read it we can't
actually read this method in this plot
in a different class if it's set to
private so that's why you need to make
it public the other thing I want to do
is that it's just synchronized
now synchronized I'm not going to go
ahead and explain it and I'm gonna also
copy and paste into here
synchronized basically on a glance it
helps with with threading okay so it
helps the threads to run properly
basically it's better it's like a safety
precaution a precaution what am i doing
precaution it's like a safety precaution
when you're when you're using threads
okay so put public synchronized for it
mate but make sure it's public yeah most
more thing alrighty so and now when our
applet starts what do we want to do we
want to we want to initiate we want to
run this method so it's called start so
display dot start alrighty
and similarly when we when we want to
stop our applet then you know we do the
exact same thing we just read display
don't stop and that's it
that is literally it so if you're on the
code you won't notice anything different
at all it's still the same old thing but
we've got our aplicar now this is the
most important thing alrighty so now
we're actually up to the stage well
we're gonna export our code so let's go
ahead file export now last time we
exported as a runnable jar file now we
don't need to do that we need to export
it as a jar file okay so this is not a
runnable file that you can double click
this is just like a what's the best way
to explain this it's it's just a fire
it's just like an archive of all of our
classes alright so jar file
the Java Java I'll hit next right now
I'm under here just hit source and
resources we don't need to export all
these class path and project settings
don't worry about that
just make sure that you're exporting all
of your source code obviously and all of
your resources like the textures if you
want because you need the textures to
obviously appear otherwise it'll crash
okay so that all of this should be fine
um I'm just gonna name it mine from
applet it's already here hit save and
hit finish and that's it it's exported
alrighty so what I should have done is
let me just minimize this is created a
jar file now this isn't honourable like
you can't you can't open it with this it
fell closed main class you can't like
you can't okay you can't actually want
this this is this isn't a runnable char
file this is just basically a an archive
so if you open it you'll see you know
you got your comm and you got all of our
classes here including our mind front
upper class which we just wrote and the
textures okay now our resources folder
so our source and resources folder are
all here now what we actually need to do
is I'm just gonna show you guys quickly
how to write a HTML file now this isn't
really an HTML tutorial so I'm just
gonna write the the most basic file and
I'm just gonna call it mine front mine
from what's called my front and let's go
ahead and open this text so I've just
created just open notepad right open
notepad and start typing this okay if
you know HTML off obviously you can you
can you can actually improve on this but
for the time being you know I'm not
gonna I'm gonna go through all this so
first of all it's HTML so let's just go
ahead and say that as well as HTML and
we'll close out HTML text right away I'm
actually don't think you have to do that
anymore you used to have to but I'd just
bear with me
well it's quick let's go ahead and quit
quickly give it a head in a title so the
title is just go on mine from from
applet
this is better done in Dreamweaver
actually but I know that a lot of you
guys might not have Dreamweaver is not
free let's set the background color to a
nice grey that's what I usually do so
we'll set it this is just the hex of the
color make sure that's six twos one two
three four five six
yep look and let's make it in the center
and okay now this is important okay
so guys if you don't know HTML I don't
know a lot of you probably do know HTML
because hTML is well it's not gel verts
it's just a markup language it's really
easy to learn I'm not gonna go through
that I'm sure you could find an HTML
tutorial or if you don't know what any
of these tags mean just google them but
this is important okay now basically
we've just created a basic layout and
actually I know that I actually want to
leave paragraphs and breaks so this is
just aesthetical things right so this BR
is a break
that's just like a lot that's just like
hitting Enter and paragraph P is just
like a paragraphs that leaves a bigger
space this is just this will just
aesthetically make it look good that's
all okay so and also you guys wanted a
launch Toria laughter that's a really
short one on sunday because it was my
birthday so hey here it is um alrighty
so let's go ahead and say okay so applet
code equals now this applet code is okay
this is important by the way that was
all just HTML this is obviously still
HTML but this is how we actually tell
our web browser to actually run what's
over here
so our applet code basically is asking
for the location of the class that we
want to run so in this case it's calm my
mind front mind front applet or class
okay that's what we want to run so we
need to tell it okay this is how you
find it now remember this is even though
it's in folders this is still like a
Java so what we actually need to do is
put dots instead of four slash as a
backslide
or whatever that's okay that indicates
another folder calm don't mind mine
France dot my in front applet now you
don't have to put doc class I think it
might actually no I I haven't tried it
actually you don't put your class just
my Ron output that's all and now we have
specified okay well what archive is it
in right so this is this is how to get
there once you're in this archive but
like what's the where's location of this
of this file so we just need to put
archive equals and mine front ones are
called mine front output mine front
applet jar alrighty so this is bit
malice will change by the way according
to where this is located right so
obviously this is a HTML file and this
is our archive they're in the same
folder they're both on the desktop which
is why this will work if it would be in
another folder called
I don't know Java then you'd have to go
obviously Java slash might run applet or
if it was in the previous folder you
have to do that etc etc but it's it's in
the same just keep that in mind if this
doesn't work for you of some reason
make sure the both of these files are in
the same directory that's all now also
what we need to do is actually set a
width and a and a height to this thing
so we'll set the width equal to 800
because that's worth of our frame and
height equal to 600 because that's the
heart of our frame and that's that's all
we need to do it let's just close the
upper tag and that's it alright umm
that's actually it okay
I'm pretty sure we close everything we
didn't close our body it's one thing in
the we need to close all right hit ctrl
s um oh you know file save and this sit
should run okay so first of all let's
actually rename this and instead of text
no I should probably explain this
shouldn't I okay if you don't have
extensions already here
I think you need to go tools turn into a
windows tutorial view and make sure that
you are that hide extensions for known
file types is not on otherwise we'll
just see it as this and you'll be like
okay well how do I change this to an
HTML file because it's currently a text
document as you can see so make sure
that this uncheck that and here we go so
now we've got dot text so right click
rename and let's change this to HTML and
hit yes so now this will open with your
default web browser for me it's Chrome
so don't click on this to open it and
hopefully this will work
I'll give us an error that we can
quickly diagnose at least alrighty
you complete my computer's being slow
today okay so Java the Java plug-in
needs to your permission to run run this
time whatever doesn't matter it's
loading and here it is radio it worked
and as you can see the frame rate is
pretty much the same as if we run it it
was 42 yep that's the same as if we run
it in a jar in a runnable jar file you
sit at our java is happily working here
alrighty and we it's playable game it's
in it's in our web browser as you can
see I just the reason is well I didn't
really explain this but the reason I
actually left so many spaces here as
well was because like this stuff was
because you know I didn't want the
applet to be at the very top of the
screen I just left a few spaces here
that's all this - it says esthetical
don't worry about that you don't nee
that um but yeah that's how you put an
applet and I put it into the center
obviously by using this send attack and
added a nice background color so that it
wouldn't be white
no there's anything wrong with white
it's just that well it has your eyes um
already so that's our game in a web
browser and obviously you can upload
this to web site do whatever you want
with it that's I guess that's it for
this tutorial
umm one quick thing also hit the like
button if you like this because well it
helps me out and the other thing was
yeah on Sunday we're gonna be studying
walls and obstacles hopefully we'll
definitely actually
so um that'll be a huge tutorial don't
want to miss that but the other thing is
like I've actually run out of ideas for
what to do in these midweek episodes so
because my original plan was to show you
guys how to export it as a runnable jar
file and how to you know export it as an
applet but yeah so if you guys have any
requests which don't modify the source
code I know you guys are probably gonna
be saying or next midweek apposite
episode had a gun to the game like
that's that's huge like that's for the
actual Sunday night episodes well this
is some they're not in Australia when I
upload it probably Sunday morning in the
US or whatever but yeah so something
that doesn't really okay yeah so you
could say that occurs is here but can't
really do anything about it now there's
probably a way to fix it I'm not gonna
deal with that now that it works which
is what's important
something that doesn't modify our code
that much like we just added a new
applicant class that didn't change our
game it's just um you know it was just
like a like a quick tip to a 16 minute
42nd and Counting tip on how to actually
run this as you know how's it now put in
our web browser so if you guys have any
requests for next week's midweek episode
then drop a comment below and be sure to
LIKE the video if you liked it and uh
yeah I'll see you guys on Sunday goodbye